aujourd'hui au cannet bonjour bienvenue
dans mon appart et
wade jamais votre appart et ouais
un peu trop de photos de moi mais
c'est super ouais bonne impression aux
premières impressions positif c'est déjà
bien ouais mais ça c'est que vous allez
bien ça c'est un vrai feu attention rien
je sais pas trop quand même ma main je
sens c'est bien ça grave vous allez bien
guillaume canet je vais bien c'est la
course ouais c'est un peu la course je
vous laisse observer vu ça vous dit
quelque chose forcément
cette vue la wii alors
c'est ben ali lundi ouais c'est sauzon
oui où se situe l'action de lui ouais
tout à fait votre dernier film dont on
va parler bien entendu ouais vous allez
aimer tourner là bas j'ai j'ai adoré
tourner là bas je connaissais pas
l'endroit je connaissais l'île de houat
j'avais passé du temps plus jeune mais
je n'avais jamais été à belle-ile et je
me suis rabattu sur ce sur belle isle
parce qu'il veut la falaise et le côté
intéressant pour nous pour mon film un
film dont on va parler bien sûr un film
énigmatique un peu déconcertant un peu
comme le format de cette émission avec
une voix dans votre tête mais on va pas
déflorer davantage évidemment on va voir
la bande annonce dans un petit instant
ya bélisle et puis il ya évidemment le
cap ferret un tout ça ce sont des
endroits avec la vue plongeante sur la
mer que vous affectionnez
particulièrement c'est là que vous vous
ressourcer dans ces endroits là parce
que vous êtes un solitaire qui a peur
d'être seule comme dirait laurent
lafitte c'est vous guillaume canet
oui c'est assez juste je suis un celui
dit ça de moins à l'oreille et 10 à noël
mais il a il a raison je pense que c'est
un peu ça c'est vrai
j'ai besoin de la nature en tout cas
pour me faire des mises à jour en fait
j'ai besoin de la vibration de la nature
pour pour me reconnecter et et faire des
mises à jour régulières
alors là c'est pas tout à fait la nature
mais c'est une situation un peu hybride
avec une voix un appartement vite
finalement c'est peut-être ça qui
ouvrait une information des halles ouais
mais c'est bien ouais c'est bien c'est
vrai le moi je suis seul et puis pas
complètement c'est pas mal mais j'ai
l'habitude et à cette petite voix dans
ma tête alors 16 h un effet un film oui
on va regarder la bande annonce et vous
allez nous expliquer effectivement tout
ce qu'il ya dans votre tête vous êtes
peut-être plusieurs parfois regardons
d'abord la bande annonce avec sa soeur
mercredi ça s'appelle lui
tout quitte la maison sans dire au
revoir aux enfants public a besoin de
s'isoler de réfléchir